[Applaudissements]
des stars l'an dernier oui c'est vrai on
m'avait proposé aurait bas mais alors et
que c'était pareil m'avait dit on à 6
heures de boulot à faire dans ce n'est
absolument pas mais cyril jeu
franchement voilà on se le dit moi je
pars mais j'ai passé une année super
avec vous je vous aime bien mais voilà
vous avez cru en moi vous m'avez mis sur
ce plateau l'âge et j'aime autant
applaudi autant ri je me suis jamais
autant éclaté j'ai rencontré des gens
formidables d'autres un peu moins moi en
tout cas cette émission d'aujourd'hui
est pas là
tu es ma meilleure balance tous ces
produits c'est le problème de cette
émission c'est comme ça c'est pas le
problème c'est exactement le
fonctionnement cette émission là c'est
qu'on est libre et c'est ça qui fait la
force de tp on sait pas ce qui va nous
arriver nous les téléspectateurs n'ont
plus les mêmes noms et voilà donc merci
rigueur pour le projet on verra on va là
là là de nouveau je sais pas erik hamrén
mais honnêtement il n'y a rien de
concret on m'a juste proposer des trucs
qui me donne envie comme je suis venu
ici avec le coeur on dit à ton lien ça
ça me parle j'y vais je fonce à dire à
quoi en tout cas erika et je vous le dis
et devant les téléspectateurs et je le
dis à vous le savez si vous avez besoin
de moi pour quoi que ce soit eh ben vous
m'appelez m6 a besoin d'un blouson tout
ça je vous dis non mais vraiment voilà
non mais je vous le dis pas ce que je
vais trouver vraiment très loyal avec
l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste et
vous arrivez toujours ici avec le
sourire et je pense que voilà la plupart
des gens ici vous aime beaucoup et moi
j'étais content de vous avoir avec nous
non mais franchement voilà mais vraiment
rester sincère lui rendent hommage
véritable ans parce que j'ai les offres
de toutes les missions et c'est une des
seules j'ai jamais entendu dire du mal
de qui que ce soit donc c'est un amour
donc un amour